if I have to give up my career for you
to build something and then you cheat on
me and we have to get divorced big man
give me my money
because you feel like a ways but that's
how the courts see it the court see it
as it's fair for a woman to get this
like we were saying about the West the
reason that this is a law is because the
courts have decided not women that it's
fair for women especially where they
couldn't maybe have an income
no but the context is the court is a
business it makes money men pay into the
court system I've said no more and then
women claim legal aid which is taxpayers
money which meant other taxpayers
because they're working right then what
happens is is basically women get half
of the man's money because he's working
he has to pay the legal fees he has to
pay child support which also goes to the
woman and then there's a level of
entitlement that women think that
they're entitled to why your children
his children are entitled to it because
they're the children but you as a woman
I'm not yeah and again coming back real
quick coming back to even the cultural
differences me myself in my faith when
you get married the woman has a diary
and that's the only thing she's entitled
to when she's married to the man he pays
for her upkeep and her life of what she
had so if she started off as a
Millionaire's daughter he needs to
provide that lifestyle if she started
off as on ten dollars a month that's the
minimum he has to offer when they get
divorced she's not entitled to any of
his money or assets while she's working
in the marriage she's her money is her
money his money is their money if that
makes sense when they now divorce she
doesn't take any of his manual assets
and if they have children he has to pay
responsibility for his children and his
assets get divided to his children
nothing to her so naturally I come from
a thing where we have like a prenup
let's say because a woman can't marry as
a gold digger this country this or these
Concepts have come from where courts
have decided it's fair for women to get
this much because when they're left
they're left with no think yeah but it's
called business because then pay into
listen have you ever been to call have
you ever actually had to pay if you
realize the amount that people can make
oh sorry the amount that people have to
pay for example with children there's a
lot of money that goes into the court
system isn't a recent this is a recent
rule this wasn't around 200 years ago
what the men and women dividing their
assets when they divorce
there's also nothing stopping women from
working today so exactly so but then but
the courts do take that into
consideration I'll put it like this when
women say they're a single mother yeah
they're they're not a single mother
they're a woman with children yeah and
then they become available if they want
to right if a man is if a man wants to
look after his kids and you are
separated you're not a single mother
she's a single woman yeah yeah she's a
single woman Spa in the court she'll say
I'm a single mother I need the money for
to look after the kids blah blah blah
right
and she has control of how the money is
spent so she can spend it and she's
actually she won't and she's
incentivized to not let the man see the
kids like she's literally paid too
because she gets more child support if
if the father doesn't see the kids yeah
and I think that's toxic women who put
themselves before their children no yeah
but again A woman has to look at herself
and say what if like you said it's about
her children from then if she then
thinks about herself that's her as a
woman okay well I can flip it back to
the earlier conversation when we were
saying about the whole dynamic that we
were talking about where it was
and that comes into play because the
woman is not thinking about the children
she's thinking about herself how she
feels at that given time
based no not real but based on looking
through the phone getting angry all
these feelings what's happened the
projections that have happened lack of
no emotional management and then when
you're in no no no when you're in the
courthouse remember you have to provide
evidence at in court for why you want to
see your children right if a woman says
this is I don't want my partner or ex to
see my kids because it's abusive he's
toxic he sent me these messages on
social media he did this this and this
and screenshots with were given to the
court she could put in an injunction
without that just that evidence alone
now that man has to pay to get the
injunctions removed prove his innocence
then pays to see his kids and pay pay
for his children even though he's not
seeing them okay so then he's
financially drained okay I feel like
there's a lot of responsibility taking
off the man cheating for example a man
who's married and has children he should
understand if I cheat I'm going to break
my home there should not it's a
responsibility on himself
we could say it's wrong but he shouldn't
lose how I'm not saying he's dead I'm
not saying that I'm saying if a woman
now goes on his phone and she's now
looking she shouldn't find anything
right she shouldn't because he should
also adhere to his own responsibility
and not do anything right no no but why
was she looking because she suspects
this she suspects because he might be
doing something yeah
something you already know the answer
cheating is selfish a man cheating but
also breaking up that home is selfish is
that but so he also needs to understand
his actions are going to break the home
what action is more heavy yeah your man
cheating or the fact that a woman
destroys her home for her children what
act is more heavy in a marriage respect
should still be there whether you like
your wife or not you should respect her
if you're going to step up now can you
answer his questions
what what has more weight in it yeah a
man stepping out just busting a nut or
you breaking up a home where your kids
will suffer the results but you've just
you've what is more heavy what's more
heavy you as a man could have created
what is more heavy the man so the man
cheating
okay okay this right there modern women
selfish I swear to God I swear to god
stop it stop it stop it stop it you're
over talking me on my own show that's
rude uh like this is this is this is the
epitome modern women selfish because you
think because he did something to you
that that is more heavy than you doing
something to your children no I'm not
saying that I didn't say that this is
this is what okay okay
okay you've talked a lot today okay I've
given you a lot of mic time and I'm
saying like that like I actually forgot
what I was gonna say
I'm saying is the man especially when he
has children he needs to understand the
repercussions is the woman's going to be
hurt she might not get over it he's
breaking up his family home he's putting
his selfish needs ahead of his child no
no no he's not she's breaking up the
whole like this is like like women do
something and we still put the
accountability on men you broke up the
home
you chose to leave okay I think we're
not understanding a man stepping up with
transparency is very different to a man
going behind her back and causing her if
he said to her let me finish sorry if he
said to her do you know what babe I'm I
need to sexually [ __ ] this woman because
that is that is something of me I love
you I want to be in a marriage with you
but I just need to step out you're
probably still gonna hold up hold up no
wait let me finish if she then decides
to leave that's on her if she decides to
say do you know what he's told me and I
can't tolerate it I'm gonna break up my
child that's fine but if he's now gone
behind her back and she's found out and
she's reacting and said this
disrespectful very different this is a
nonsense this is just like a Fluff it's
like if you chose to leave then you're
responsible for leaving can I just like
with these two people here as she was
there at the beginning and she worked
just as hard as him I can understand the
wanting half but what I don't understand
is that if they've got children
and he cheated
and she's willing to screw up the family
because he's cheated everybody's gonna
say oh no she's right she's entitled to
because she cheated she's a woman but
look what she's putting that child
through by getting married again
so what's worse putting your child
through a second bad relationship or
sticking and working out with the
original father sorry I I'm struggling
yeah to understand how we're missing the
fact that he put the family in this
situation I don't think no look I'm not
saying that what he did isn't wrong I'm
not saying what he did is wrong I'm just
saying that two Realms don't make her at
100 but him stepping out yeah and button
on us and we discussed how meaningless
sex can be to men we know how
meaningless it can be here so you're
gonna you're gonna break up a home over
something that was meaningless he's not
having it doesn't have another
relationship he's not providing
resources he doesn't love this woman
regardless of the situation as to why he
did it the reasons for him stepping out
do not equate to the reasons you're
breaking up at home
eating is different like how many women
get attention from other men all the
time all the time look at how half the
girls on the show like they'll be in a
relationship I'll look at their
Instagram ass pic ass pick ass pick
that's cheating too but the thing is is
that everybody's saying that oh then
cheating's bad you're not supposed to
cheat but what's worse
forgiving your husband for cheating or
divorcing when you've got children and
put in your childhood a second marriage
that you've left up
I was going to be more traumatic for the
child at the end of the day we've all
been saying that when you get married
it's about the child I'm not going to
say that what he done was right but what
I'm saying that what she done was worse
hmm because she didn't just leave and
say I'm gonna raise my child we're going
to work out and co-parent or I'm gonna
forgive you
she went and married somebody else and
now she's getting divorced with that
person and that's what she's putting out
I think it's funny that we're saying
that the woman isn't taking
accountability this times the problem
starts with the man
no it does I just said that but you know
it's the way the way I think about
relationships and like marriage and
stuff yeah
I think it's it's a partnership
absolutely it is yeah I have to be right
to be able if I have children I have to
be right to be able to take care of my
children my partnership has to be strong
and solid for my children to be a good
result of this part this great
partnership right I understand that
that's cool I personally don't believe
in
stay in in any situation because of my
children because I believe the way I'm
set up I might be more useful to my
children I might be a better mother to
my children if I'm not in a toxic
situation firm in it
please let me finish I don't believe in
saying in a situation if someone cheats
for me to me I class that has toxic as
toxic because I know how it would affect
me this is personal to me so I don't
believe in me staying in a situation
because I didn't want to break the facts
in my opinion
in a marriage you know you should know
your partner so you know what it is that
I want what I will tolerate and what I
won't tolerate you know the boundaries
that I've set you know the vowels that I
that I shared with you if you cheat on
me
there's you you should have been you're
aware that there's a risk that I might
walk away
so if the family breaks up you are the
starting point of that you started that
basically you said there's a risk it's
not a definite there's a risk
it was a definite
you said that he must know there's a
risk okay there's a risk yes it's a risk
infinite and he took the risk led us to
a broken family yeah
managing your emotions
managing my emotions does not mean me
tolerating [ __ ] does not mean
neglecting how I feel to be mature okay
okay okay okay as an adult it literally
does
literally it literally means managing
your emotions when things just don't go
your way
but
I don't I don't know because
these are the same women
when they're pregnant you're going to
get the hormones you're going to get
feelings your feelings change then it
will change but yeah
I'm gonna feel the same when I've had a
child when you've had a child talking to
you come back and tell me that when
you've had a child because as far as I'm
concerned it's totally different because
you're quite happy to say I've just
turned around and said I'm not excusing
his cheating he's married right to the
woman she's decided that she can't
accept his cheating so she's going to
divorce him fair enough what is worse
exception is cheating or putting the
child through a second marriage
because surely it's got to be better to
forgive him move on get counseling for
her trauma and then get on with the
relationship and raise her child then it
is to put her child through a second
toxic relationship I hear you that's
what I'm trying to say and if we're
gonna turn around and say put your
children first all the women are going
to say oh my hormones I want to have my
child I felt like that's what I'm trying
to say okay like a person that has no
children